mais c'est pas vrai j'en ai assez quoi
j'en peux plus je te jure j'en peux plus
j'en ai marre j'eni plein le cul de
tester jeux pourris j'en ai
marac
attends lestr non c'est j'ai 950 km pour
venir à Paris tu crois que je jouer non
mais c'est bon rapporte un café
aussi c'est fini quoi c'est bon quoi
quoi
[Rires]
j'en ai marre de tester ces jeux pourris
mais je te jure j'en ai marre mais quoi
quoi attends ah c'est un ouf
il excuse-moi je peux pas j'ai des
pour il y
a Jurassic par B jeu ça oui ça c'est un
bon jeu voilà ça ça fait plaisir pour
une
et voilà et donc je serai dans rogame
Test et pour une fois je vais tester un
jeu qui me plaît pour de
[Musique]
vrai